muy bien una vez considerado lo anterior
por qué no pasar a la siguiente parte
del páncreas que se conoce como el
páncreas endocrino en realidad esta es
la parte del páncreas más famosa
escuchamos más sobre esta parte como
veremos en un minuto porque tiene mucho
que ver con la diabetes el páncreas
endocrino libera hormonas en lugar de
las sales o enzimas que vimos antes
libera hormonas que van al torrente
sanguíneo y a otras partes del cuerpo
tal vez al hígado al intestino o incluso
hasta los músculos para hacer que
sucedan cosas la forma en que se
organiza el páncreas endocrino es
mediante islotes de células existen tres
tipos principales de células en los
islotes de las que vamos a hablar y
todas están presentes hasta cierto punto
en cada islote o grupo de células en el
páncreas veamos uno por uno tenemos las
células alfa estas células liberan una
hormona que se llama glucagón y la
función principal del glucagón es tomar
cosas como el club cogen o qué es un
montón de moléculas de glucosa que están
apiladas una encima de otra y
descomponer la sal monómeros
o moléculas de glucosa más pequeñas de
modo que se produce glucosa a partir del
glucógeno cada vez que se libera
glucagón escribir glucagón aquí arriba
el glucagón es responsable de la
descomposición de un montón de
macromoléculas no solo de carbohidratos
lo haré más claro escribiendo que el
glucagón causa descomposición
el siguiente tipo de células en los
islotes que tenemos y quizá el más
famoso de todos es el tipo de células
beta las células beta almacenan y
liberan insulina ahora cuando escuchas
insulina debes pensar muchas cosas
porque la insulina es responsable de
muchas funciones por un lado la insulina
causa lo contrario de esta reacción
donde en lugar de descomponer el
glucógeno en glucosa la insulina hace
que se almacene o se acumule la glucosa
en glucógeno así que la insulina hace
exactamente lo contrario para hacer esto
más claro nuevamente no es sólo para
carbohidratos sino que es para
reconstruir muchas cosas entonces
escribiré la insulina es responsable de
la acumula
o almacenamiento de macromoléculas pero
lo más importante que podemos mencionar
sobre la insulina es que es la hormona
que es responsable de la enfermedad
conocida como diabetes
podríamos tener tutoriales completos
sobre diabetes lo que hace y lo que
significa pero en esencia lo que es
básico es que la diabetes ocurre y causa
daño a nuestros cuerpos cuando tenemos
demasiada glucosa demasiada glucosa
flotando en nuestro cuerpo demasiada
azúcar de acuerdo y esto sucede porque
la insulina no funciona correctamente la
glucosa no se acumula y almacena en el
glucógeno como debería en cambio corre
por todo el cuerpo esa es la razón por
la que se produce enfermedad ocular
nerviosa y renal esa es la frase clave
que usamos en medicina para describir la
diabetes es una enfermedad nerviosa
ocular y del riñón porque con demasiada
glucosa con el tiempo seremos incapaces
de ver los nervios más frecuentemente de
los pies no pueden detectar pinchazos
picaduras o daños y a la larga puede
causar amputación los riñones dejan
con el tiempo pueden conducir a diálisis
y causar muerte prematura además de
estas tres la glucosa recorre todo el
cuerpo y causa muchas otras cosas como
ataque cardíaco temprano y otros tipos
de complicaciones otra cosa que debemos
mencionar sobre la diabetes es que hay
dos tipos hay diabetes tipo 1 y tipo 2
la diferencia entre el tipo 1 y el tipo
2 es la causa todo esto apunta de nuevo
a la insulina en la diabetes tipo 1 no
hay insulina la persona que tiene
diabetes tipo 1 no tiene producción de
insulina es por eso que no se puede
almacenar el azúcar en el glucógeno no
se puede guardar por lo que está en
todas partes eso causa enfermedad
nerviosa ocular y renal entre otras
complicaciones en la diabetes tipo 2
si hay producción de insulina pero los
receptores de insulina son
disfuncionales los receptores de
insulina no funcionan incluso si se
produce insulina y va a donde se supone
que debe ir en el cuerpo estos
receptores no responderán y es como si
no hubiera insulina hay mucho más que
podemos decir
pero cerraremos nuestra conversación
sobre diabetes por ahora y volveremos a
esto más tarde pasemos al tercer tipo de
células en los islotes que hay en el
páncreas y son las células delta estas
células liberan una hormona llamada
somatostatina que es la principal
hormona que libera el páncreas porque su
trabajo principal es detener los
trabajos de todas las hormonas que están
activas y estas hormonas pueden incluir
como hemos hablado antes cosas como
glucagón insulina y otras hormonas que
están contenidas en el tracto
gastrointestinal como la col existo
quinina la somatostatina entrará y
detendrá las otras hormonas ese es su
papel principal así que este es el
páncreas endocrino y antes hablamos del
páncreas exocrino el páncreas es
responsable de mucho no es de extrañar
que los cirujanos tengan la frase come
cuando puedas duerme cuando puedas y no
te metas con el páncreas